اكتماله اسطوره ميسي ومونديال قطر اثار
مصر الخالده مسرحا لعرضين عالميين عوده
الى الساحه الغنائيه بعد غياب احداث سعيده
تغيرات شكليه جذريه وترينداد طريفه من
الابرز في 2022
[موسيقى]
قبل ايام قليله اختتم الحدث الابرز لهذا
العام مونديال فيفا قطر 2022 باكتمال
اسطوره ميسي وتتويجا تاريخي طال انتظاره
لمنتخب الارجنتين بكاس العالم لكره القدم
تحت قياده بعد مباراه النهائيه وصفت
بالاكثر دراميه في تاريخ البطوله قاتل
فيها راقصه تانجو مع ديوك الفرنسيه على
الفوز باللقب حتى اللحظات الاخيره من
الشوطين الاضافيين الى ان قالت اقدام
الارجنتينيين وكفاء مليان ومارتينيز
كلمتها الاخيره في ركلات الترجيح قبل ميسي
الكاس حامل للكره الذهبيه ورفعه عاليا
مرتديا البشته العربيه بينما كان
الماتشاتوس يطلقون صرخات الفرح في سماء
استاد الوسيل بالدوحه
تردد اصداؤها في بوينوس والعالم وسيبقى
مونديال قطر في الذاكره طويلا بالجدل
الحقوقي الذي رافقه والاسقاطات السياسيه
وارقامه القياسيه ورفعه سقفه معايير
البطوله وحسن تنظيمه اول مره على ارض
عربيه شهدت صعود منتخب المغرب اسود الاطلس
كاول فريق افريقيا وعربي الى مربع الكبار
الذهبي وهزيمه بطلي العالم في كره القدم
بنسختي 2018 و 2022 من منتخبين عربيين
الاخضر المنتخب السعودي ونصور قرطاج
المنتخب التونسي دموع الاسطوره رونالدو في
اخر نسخه الموندياليه له دموع نيمار
ورفاقه دموع سواريز واحتفالات النصر
الابطال المغاربه مع امهاتهم وابطال
الارجنتين مع عائلاتهم وكشخه المشجعين
بالعقال العربي كل ذلك سيبقى خالدا في
ذاكره مشجعي الساحره المستدير
ومن قطر الى مصر التي احتضنت في عام 2022
من عروض الازياء العالميه بين اثارها
الخالده عرض ازياء خاص بدار ديول الفرنسيه
في سابقه ثانيه الاولى من نوعها في منطقه
الاهرامات واحتفال دار ستيفان ريتش
الايطاليه بذكرى تاسيسها الخمسين بين
احضان معبد حجب سوت بالاقصر وحظي الحدثان
باهتمام الصحافه العالميه وفي مصر ايضا
احياها المطربه امال ماهر في مدينه
العلمين على الساحل الشمالي اول حفل لها
بعد غياب عامين عن الحفلات ووضعها هذا
الحفل حدا لشائعات اقلقت محبيها حول
اختفائها
يا ليله بيتغدوا
[موسيقى]
مني انا هامسكك يا هواي وبين جفنك
ليه وفي السعوديه
جلال بمهرجان بالفصحى في الرياض بتفاعل
كبير على مواقع التواصل في المملكه
والعالم وذلك بعد ما يزيد على الثلاث عقود
من غيابها عن الوقوف على المسرح واحتفى
جمهور موسم الرياض باول حفل هيفاء وهبي في
السعوديه
كما شهد الموسم نسخه جديده من الحدث
الموسيقي الضخم مهرجان ساوند واعاد النجم
المصريه منى زكي الى المسرح بعد انقطاع
طويل في عرض بعنوان الوش الثاني بمشاركه
نخبه من نجوم الكوميديا المصريين كما عاد
النجم المصري احمد السقا في موسم الرياضي
المسرحي ايضا بطل لنسخه جديده من المسرحيه
الشهيره سيده الجميله التي لعب بطوله
نسختها الاولى الفنانه الراحلان فؤاد
المهندس وشويكار سنه 1969
والى لبنان حيث اهدت فرقه مياس شيئا من
الفرح للبنانيين وسط الظروف فيهم
الاقتصاديه الصعبه بفوزها بلقب الموسم
السابع عشر من برنامج مواهب امريكا بعد
تقديمها عروضا وصفت باستثنائيه خلال
منافساتها على لقب هذا الموسم فستقبلت بعد
الفوز بحفاوه في مطار بيروت وحقق منتخب
لبنان لكره السله نجاحين بارزين هذا العام
باحرازه بطوله العرب الرابعه والعشرين
للمنتخبات في تونس وتاهله لبطوله كاس
العالم 2023 للمره الرابعه في تاريخه
واحتفل فيروزين في لبنان والعالم العربي
بعيد ميلاد معشوقتهم الفنانه اللبنانيه
فيروز السابع والثامين وكانت هديه العيد
وابنتها ريم الرحباني لمحبي السيده فيديو
فيديو
القمر شمعه وحيده على كعكه ميلادها
ومن الاحداث السعيده التي حضرت بتفاعل
كبير في العالم العربي خلال العام 2022
خبروا خطوبه ولي العهد الاردني الامير
حسين بن عبد الله الثاني والسعوديه رجوى
خالد ال سيف وزفاف الفنان المغربي سعد
المجرد على سيده الاعمال غيث العلاج
والفنانين المصريين محمد فراج وبسنت شوقي
واعلان المطرب الاماراتي حسين الجسمي
زواجه في اخر العام
اللبناني مروان خوري
وانا بادبك
العربيه التي تفعل معها رواد مواقع
التواصل في العالم العربي وعالميا ايضا
على التيك توك رقصه ميريام فارس على
وقعتبول في اغنيتها هذا الحلو وحققت اغنيه
صحصح لنانسي عجرم ومارشميلو اصداء كبيره
على مواقع التواصل كما تفاعل عدد من
النجوم المصريين على نحو طريف مع الصوره
المزعومه لابو الهول المغماض العينين
والتي اكد العديد من خلال الاثار عدم
صحتها بالمطلق بعد ما تصدره قائمه
المواضيع الرائجه على مواقع التواصل في
مصر
[موسيقى]
واخيرا وعلى سيره النجوم
والمفاجاه بشكل الفنانين تامر حسني واصاله
بتفاعل كبير بين الرواد سوشيال ميديا في
العالم العربي هذا العام مع عادل الجده لا
مجددا حول عمليات التجميل وضرورتها
وتاثيرها